this election was a fraud
this it was a rigged election
you heard the claims time and time again
but there is no evidence there was fraud
in the 2020 election now the eight news
now i-team with a report detailing
election security right here in clark
county and we're also hearing from the
man in charge and in fact this is a
topic that i team's david charns has
stayed on top of for years now so david
what'd you find out can you imagine the
election was two years ago at this point
we're still talking about it and this
independent audit found no issues with
how we vote by mail it's a process that
without any evidence faced widespread
scrutiny tonight the man in charge of
elections right here in our valley says
he's proud of his team's work and they
are preparing for what's coming this
november
what makes you come through these doors
every day there's a lot of satisfaction
in knowing that you're serving democracy
it's an important job in an american
tradition as registrar of voters joe
gloria runs elections here in clark
county it's a job he's held since 2013.
nevada and clark county
have created
this crisis but nothing prepared him for
what he would face in 2020. the
challenges were tremendous
without dealing with what we had to deal
with in the general election with the
questioning
questioning of the integrity of what we
do
nearly two years later several lawsuits
and a secretary of state review found no
widespread fraud this audit obtained by
the 8 news now i-team addressing mail-in
ballots finding no issues with the clark
county processes including how ballots
are printed mailed returned and counted
i think we're very excited that an
independent agency took a look at what
we did
showed clearly that we did
due diligence from start so what was
going through your mind when people were
saying the machines weren't working the
ballots were tampered with
the votes were changed we did receive
some some
language that was concerning i think
mainly what i like to focus on is the
fact that
my staff that came in here was having to
deal with coming to work and seeing 100
protesters outside and some of them are
armed gloria says the keys to ward off
misinformation are facts and
transparency and he's preparing for an
onslaught of fraud allegations ahead of
this november well they're not surprises
anymore so we know what's coming
and so far prosecutors have charged just
one person with voter fraud here in
nevada from the 2020 election and as we
have reported that person first
said somebody mailed in his deceased
wife's ballot and then he fessed up that
it was him all along denise i remember
that report all right david thank you
the mail-in voting law state lawmakers
passed last year allows you to opt out
of receiving a mail-in ballot if you
don't want one now you do have until
september 9th to do that and that's just
a couple of weeks away and if you don't
opt out and you want to vote in person
you can still show up to your polling
place that's no problem